>> Tucker: WHITE HOUSE
PHYSICIANS MONITOR EVERYTHING
ABOUT A PRESIDENT INCLUDING HIS
COGNITIVE ABILITY.
MOST PRESIDENTS DON’T TALK ABOUT
THAT, OF COURSE, BUT THIS
PRESIDENT WAS HAPPY TO IN GREAT
DETAIL WHEN ASKED BY DR. SIEGEL.
WATCH.
>> PRESIDENTIAL HEALTH OR HEALTH
OF A CAN ATTEMPT WILL BE ON THE
TABLE, OF COURSE, AS IT ALWAYS
IS.
SOMEBODY ALWAYS ASKING FOR THAT.
I SAW A LOT ABOUT YOUR HEALTH.
WHAT DO YOU THINK SHOULD COME
OUT WHERE THE ATTENTION
REGARDING VICE PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> WELL MY THINK WE HAVE TO BE
IN GOOD HEALTH.
I TELL YOU WHAT, THIS IS A VERY
IMPORTANT JOB TO PUT IT MILDLY.
THERE IS NOTHING LIKE IT.
AND I WILL ALSO SAY I HAVE TO
WORK HARDER THAN OTHERS BECAUSE
I’VE BEEN A TECH LIKE NOBODY HAS
EVER BEEN ATTACKED.
A FAKE INVESTIGATION, RUSSIA,
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, UKRAINE,
UKRAINE, UKRAINE AND NOBODY’S
GONE THROUGH AND I’VE DONE MORE
THAN ANY PRESIDENT IN THE
HISTORY.
NO PRESIDENT HAS DONE WHAT WE
HAVE DONE, REBUILDING THE
MILITARY, JUDGES.
WE WILL BE UP TO ALMOST 300
JUDGES INCLUDING TWO GREAT
SUPREME COURT JUDGES AT THE END
OF THIS TERM.
SO WHAT IS REALLY SOMETHING THAT
IS BEEN GREAT.
BUT YOU NEED STAMINA.
YOU NEED PHYSICAL HEALTH, AND
YOU NEED MENTAL HELP.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE SO MUCH FROM
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE, FIRST,
THEY SAY HE WANTS TO TAKE OVER
THE WORLD.
HE’S GOING TO TAKE OVER THE
WORLD, HE’S A DICTATOR.
THE NEXT WORLD, THEY WILL SAY
HE’S CRAZY.
THE NEXT INCOMPETENT IN THE NEXT
DAY SOMETHING ELSE.
SO THE LAST TIME I WAS AT THE
HOSPITAL, PROBABLY A YEAR AGO OR
LESS THAN A YEAR AGO, I ASKED
THE DOCTOR.
IS THERE SOME KIND OF COGNITIVE
TEST THAT I CAN TAKE?
BECAUSE I’VE BEEN HEARING ABOUT
IT.
BECAUSE I WANT TO SHUT THESE
PEOPLE UP.
THEY ARE FAKE NEWS.
THEY MAKE UP STORIES.
I MEAN, LIKE I WILL GO AND WITH
AN INTERVIEW WITH YOU AND I
DIDN’T SAY YOU COULD ASK DUMB IT
CAN’T ASK ME ANYTHING.
I DID ONE WITH CHRIS WALLACE AND
HE WAS NICE ENOUGH TO SAY I WANT
TO TELL THE AUDIENCE THERE IS NO
QUESTION OFF BALANCE.
AND IT WAS A GOOD INTERVIEW.
I LIKED IT, AND HE ENJOYED.
BUT I DIDN’T SAY YOU CAN ONLY
ASK THIS.
IF YOU ARE IN THE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENCY, YOU HAVE TO BE
SHARP.
SO THEY ARE SAYING ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THINGS.
WHICH EVER STUCK, NONE IT STUCK
FORTUNATELY.
ONE OF THE REASONS AS I TOOK A
TEST.
I SAID TO THE DOCTOR, DR. RONNIE
JACKSON, IS THERE SOME KIND OF
AN ATTACK, ACUITY TEST?
HE SAID THERE ACTUALLY IS AND HE
NAMED IT WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE.
IT WAS 30/35 QUESTIONS AND THE
LAST QUESTIONS ARE MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT.
LIKE THE MEMORY QUESTION.
IT IS LIKE YOU WILL GO PERSON,
WOMAN, MAN, CAMERA, TV.
SO COULD YOU REPEAT THAT?
I SAID, YEAH.
PERSON, WOMAN, MAN, CAMERA, TV.
OKAY, THAT IS VERY GOOD.
IF YOU GET IT IN ORDER, YOU GET
EXTRA POINTS.
OKAY, NOW IS ASKING OTHER
QUESTIONS, OTHER QUESTIONS.
AND THEN, 10 MINUTES, 15 MINUTES
LATER, REMEMBER THE FIRST
QUESTION, NOT THE FIRST BUT THE
TENTH QUESTION?
GIVE US THAT AGAIN.
AND YOU GO PERSON, WOMAN, MAN,
CAMERA, TV.
IF YOU GET IT IN ORDER, YOU GET
EXTRA POINTS.
I SAID NOBODY GETS IT IN ORDER.
IT’S ACTUALLY NOT THAT EASY BUT
FOR ME IT WAS EASY.
THAT IS NOT AN EASY QUESTION.
IN OTHER WORDS, THEY ASK YOU,
THEY GIVE YOU FIVE NAMES AND YOU
HAVE TO REPEAT THEM AND THAT’S
OKAY.
IF YOU REPEAT THEM OUT OF ORDER,
IT IS OKAY, BUT YOU KNOW, NOT AS
GOOD.
BUT THEN WHEN YOU GO BACK ABOUT
20, 25 MINUTES LATER AND THEY
SAY GO BACK TO THAT QUESTION AND
THEY DON’T TELL YOU THIS.
GO BACK TO THAT QUESTION AND
REPEAT THEM.
CAN YOU DO IT?
CAN YOU GO PERSON, WOMAN, MAN,
CAMERA, TV.
THEY SAY, THAT IS AMAZING.
HOW DID YOU DO THAT?
I DO IT BECAUSE I HAVE A GOOD
MEMORY.
BECAUSE I’M COGNITIVE LEAD
THERE.
NOW, JOE SHOULD TAKE THAT TEST.
BECAUSE SOMETHING IS GOING ON.
AND I SAY THIS WITH RESPECT.
I MEAN, AND IT WILL PROBABLY
HAPPEN TO ALL OF US, RIGHT?
IT’S GOING TO HAPPEN.
WE CAN’T TAKE A CHANCE OF IT
HAPPENING.
WHEN YOU ARE DEALING WITH RUSSIA
AND NOBODY IS TOUGHER THAN ME.
NOBODY TOUGHER ON CHINA THAN ME,
I CAN TELL YOU RIGHT NOW.
THEY WOULD LOVE TO SEE JOE BIDEN
INSTEAD OF TRUMP.
WE HAVE TAKEN IN BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FROM CHINA.
THEY NEVER GAVE US ANYTHING.
THEY HAVE THE WORST YEAR BEFORE
THE PLAGUE CAME IN THEY HAVE THE
WORST YEAR AND JUST ABOUT THE
HISTORY, 67 YEARS.
THE WORST YEAR IN 57 YEARS
BEFORE THE PLAGUE.
AND WE WERE DOING GREAT.
WE HAVE THE BEST ECONOMY.
BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE SOMEBODY
THAT IS SHARP.
IF THIS PERSON IS NOT SHARP
BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU,
PRESIDENT XI IS SHARP.
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN, SHARP.
YOU DON’T HAVE ANY NONSHARP
PEOPLE THAT YOU ARE DEALING
WITH.
AND WE CAN’T HAVE SOMEBODY THAT
IS NOT 100%.
AND SO WHAT I DID, YOU KNOW, IT
IS A PUBLIC TEST.
THEY SAID, YOU KNOW, IF YOU TAKE
THIS TEST, WE MAY HAVE TO REVEAL
THIS.
IT’S ALL RIGHT.
IS IT TOUGH?
TELL ME ABOUT IT.
I’VE NEVER HEARD OF IT.
AND I GOT A PERFECT MARK.
AND THE DOCTORS SAID VERY FEW
PEOPLE CAN DO THAT.
VERY PEOPLE CAN DO THAT.
IT’S NOT THAT EASY.
OTHER QUESTIONS THAT WERE
TOUGHER THAN WHAT I JUST DID.
IT’S NOT THAT EASY, BUT AS SOON
AS THEY ANNOUNCED MY SCORE AND
THE TEST, ALL OF THIS STUFF WENT
AWAY ABOUT ME.
REMEMBER, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE 25TH AMENDMENT AND NONSENSE.
THEY SAID, WOW.
EVEN THE ENEMIES, THEY DON’T SAY
THAT ANYMORE.
BUT THEY DO SAY IT ABOUT
JOE BIDEN.
AND HONESTLY, HE SHOULD TAKE THE
TEST.
AS I WEIGH IN ON ALL VOCATION
BECAUSE YOU TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
THE COUNTRY THAT THE PERSON THAT
ARE PICKING AS A LEADER IS SHARP
AT PEOPLE THAT WANT TO DO BAD
THINGS TO US IF THEY HAVE THE
CHANCE.
YOU HAVE TO BE SHARPER THAN
THEM.
IN A CERTAIN WAY, JOE BIDEN HAS
TWO TAKE A TEST LIKE THAT ONE OR
SOMETHING ELSE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS MORE TO